wie ist die
Lage so unsere Standardfragen am Anfang
die stellen wir wirklich fast immer die
Lage viel los sagen ja heute ist
Interviewtag das heißt wie
viel also heute ich weiß nicht das ist
jetzt glaube ich das ate oder ne oder so
aber es ist ja wenn das jetzt nur heute
wä das wäre ja nichts aber das geht halt
die ganze Zeit so und zwar schon
seit Anfang Juni also anderthalb Monate
zwe Monate aber nicht jeden Tag a
Interviews doch teilweise noch viel mehr
Rekord war bisher 22 in Wien und am
selben Abend noch in die nächste Stadt
fliegen schön und dann noch auf dem
Rollfeld sitzen weil Gewitter ist und
man kann nicht weiter wird man nicht
langsam da Matsche in der Birne ja
definitiv ja ich nehme allerdings die
Freiheit ab dem Zeitpunkt wo es gibt ja
diese harte Promophase in der ich jetzt
voll drin bin so bis das Album rauskommt
die geht so zwei bis di Monate auch noch
ein bisschen wenn das Album rauskommt
weil dann kommen die fernsehdinger und
da mache ich wirklich echt alles und
reiß mir den Arsch auf aber dann nehme
ich mir die Freiheit ab dem Zeitpunkt wo
die Tour losgeht und die geht im
meistens bei mir immer so erstmal los
dann ist es irgendwie einen Monat dann
ist wieder freie einzelne Dinger und
dann kommt der nächste Teil und dann
kommen die Festivals aber ab der ersten
Tour ab da wo es live losgeht mache ich
so gut wie keine Interviews mehr und
mach nur da picke ich mir echt nur die
Sachen von all den Anfragen die Sachen
raus die mir entweder Spaß machen die
ich für erhalte weil sie weil sie jetzt
ideologisch cool sind oder die die ich
sie für sinnvoll erhalte weil sie mir
noch mal was bringen und der Platte
wieder was bringen und nicht der Werbung
machen kann so und ansonsten sage ich da
dann alles ab weil gerade wenn ich auf
Tour bin ey dann musst du echt das ist
wie im Studio sein du musst komplett
fokussiert sein auf das was du da an dem
Abend machst da kannst du nicht
irgendwie nachmittags da noch rumlabern
oder rumreisen zu irendwchen
Radiosendern du musst bei deiner Band
sein in deinem in dem kleinen Lebensraum
den man hat der schränkt sich auf den
Nightliner mit dem Betten und das
bisschen in der Location was bechillbar
ist und das ist in den seltensten Fällen
viel und da hängt man dann und das ist
aber auch wichtig dass man da zusammen
hängt was ist für dich ideologisch cool
oh auf eben bezogen ne ja du hast ger
gesag in dem Fall ist
es etwas wo ich einfach denke ich kann
ich kann meinen Namen dafür nutzen und
meine
Prominenz Leuten etwas Sinnvolles zu
vermitteln also das entsteht ja meistens
auf Anfragen hin weißt du das kann alles
mögliche sein das kann sein beim Anti G8
Gipfel aufzutreten und im Rahmen dessen
viele Interviews zu geben und zu
versuchen ich bin ja jetzt selber nicht
der
hochgestochene
Bildungs Bürger sondern ich habe ja auch
meine Sprache und mein Wissen ist auch
begrenzt aber ich glaube wenn ich als
der
den ja den man aus dem Fernsehen den
kenn für Kids einfach gerade weißt du
ich mit meinem und vielleicht auch ein
bisschen von deren Slang in meiner
Sprache dass den irgendwie erklär auf
cool mit Sonnenbrille dann habe ich auf
jeden Fall 100.000 Mal mehr Chancen als
irgend so ein verbiesterter spießiger
Lehrer oder Politiker oder sonst wer der
das in seiner Sprache tut wo man einfach
nicht zuhört in dem Moment schon wo er
den Mund aufmacht weil es ein einfach
nicht interessiert und und das sind
coole ideologische Sachen wo ich das
dann nutzen kann diesen rum und und und
und mein standing und mein meine Kunst
und da irgendwie versuchen kann was zu
vermitteln und das können die
verschiedensten Sachen sein willst du
die Welt verändern nö es wäre schön es
wäre schön wenn sich ich will jemanden
such
suchen vielleicht auch mit meiner Musik
der dann sagt ich will die Welt
verändern aber ich selber das nee das
kann ich glaube ich gar nicht hast du
nicht so im Hinterkopf es wä so
wunderschön wenn die Welt sich verändert
ich finde einfach ich ich alle wir alle
müssen die Welt verändern nee aber so
ist es ja weißt du ich was soll das ich
will die Welt verändern das ist ein Song
von Revolver HT das ist dadurch schon
scheiße nee das wir alle müssen die Welt
verändern wir alle müssen in uns uns den
das Gefühl haben
ich ich will irgendwie was besser machen
weil ich jammern und so das bringt
sowieso nichts so man muss irgendwie und
wenn man an sich selber anfängt wie der
große Michael schon sagt bei dem Mann im
Spiegel dann ist das schon mal ein
großer Fortschritt und ich wäre gerne
der der vielleicht hier und da eine
Motivation für jemanden gibt damit
anzufangen das mache ich gerne aber das
sollte auch jeder selber sein also der
Motivator für andere so ich formulier
mal was kleiner willst du eine Spur
hinterlassen ja klar und wie soll diese
Spur Aussehen
ähm aus geilen Tonträgern soll die
Bestehen am liebsten in Vinyl okay
so und dann noch so
V muss dann natürlich Platin
galvanisiert sein so stelle ich gibt
eigentlich das gibt gibt das noch dass
man eine Vinyl goldene
oderen wir haben das gemacht also mein
mein Grafiker der halt genauso ein
Perfektionist und Flasher ist wie ich
den ich quasi mit Fug und Recht und
Vertrauen mein Auge nennen kann seit
seit meinem ersten Plattencover quasi
der hat einfach so lange nicht ruhig
gegeben bis wir das irgendwie geklärt
haben dass wir noch mal richtig
aufwendige geile wenn wir schon plati
machen und das war unser Ziel und das
ist das größte dann müssen muss das auch
geil sein und richtig derbe aussehen wie
früher mit hier gvanisierung und noch
Druck auf Glas und hier und so wie man
es kennt und richtig schön designed und
das macht niemand mehr weil das ist
kostet so ein Schweinegeld diese
tonräger zu machen und das zu verpacken
und und allein das Geld quasi man bei
manchen Gold Verleihung würde ich
prognostizieren dass das Geld was mit
dieser weil Gold wurde immer weiter
runtergestuft ne so und das Geld was mit
mit mit der Platte quasi jetzt verdient
wurde mit der Goldplatte ist quasi wäre
wenn man das so macht wie früher wäre
das Geld was dann die Platten zum an die
Wand hängen Kosten deshalb macht es
keiner mehr es gibt wenn wenn überhaupt
so eine kleine lieblose CD wo dann so
mit dem Eding drauf steht PL mit dem
Nagel auf dem Brett gehauen und dann
steht Tom wone von Universal da und gibt
das in irgendeinem kleinen currybrust
IMIS dann dem Künstler gut bei dir ist
es also etwas anders du hast noch so
eine richtige ja in Anführungszeichen
benü möchteone nicht rausschneiden ich
möchte dass das also Tom bone bleib gut
was machst du richtig was andere falsch
machen sind es die Interviews oder was
ist verantwortlich für deinen Erfolg die
Interviews oder die Musik nee das
ständige lernen und
und sich verbessern und so ein Ehrgeiz
und und ich mache das so lange einfach
das ist das ich glaube das ist mein
Vorteil so dass ich ich meine wir haben
angefangen da waren wir 14 Jahre alt 15
Jahre alt ja 15 war ich und Songs zu
produzieren und aufzutreten und und das
alles unter Ausschuss der Öffentlichkeit
diese ganzen peinlichen Fehler die alle
jetzt heute machen die sofort wo alles
medial überwacht wird sich selber dann
oder wenn es keine Fernsehkameras sich
bei youtube reinstellen all diesen
Scheiß das gab's bei uns nicht wir
konnten schön selber aufs Maul fahren
und fallen und im schlimmsten Fall waren
da 200 Leute Zeugen im Haus der Jugend
so und wir haben uns ständig verbessert
immer weiter und und schon 98 waren wir
eben s weit dass wir beim bule machen
konnten was was für mich heute also
nicht nur jetzt von der Platte mal ganz
abgesehen aber wegen diesem richtig
machen ne für mich meinenstein in in
meinem Lebenslauf und in dem von Dennis
und von M weil da waren wir nur noch zu
dritt als wir die Platte gemacht haben
ist weil wir uns gesagt haben wir wir
gehen hier sowieso nur zum Major weil
wir einmal so viel Geld haben wollen
dass wir so lange im Studio sind bis wir
das bis das alles so ist wie wir das
wollen selbst wenn alle Kohle dafür
drauf geht und plus die Entscheidung wir
gehen nur zum Major wenn wir da trotzdem
weiterin alles kontrollieren können dass
es so läuft wie wir das wollen und
beides hat geklappt und natürlich hat
man da noch viele Fehler gemacht wie das
liebeslead Video daraus haben wir sofort
gelernt und haben gesagt okay wir haben
jetzt so viel Geld verballert ab jetzt
macht nur noch DJM unsere Videos oder
hat zumindest die Idee so und ab da kam
hammerht und Füchse das sind bis heute
Meilensteine in in in der zumindest in
der Rap
Video Sache in Deutschland und
und sowas bleibt halt haften bei den
Leuten und das konnten wir halt nur
machen und aus uns rausholen weil wir
vorher die Fehler gemacht haben und
jetzt ständige lernen aber auch so
innerhalb einer plattenphase das das ist
wichtig man muss ständig sich verbessern
und alles perfektionieren und dann in
Zunahme mit dem mit dem Vorteil dass der
Geschmack den ich halt habe weil ich nur
mal ein popschwein bin
m jetzt nach mit Erfahrung sagen kann
okay den haben noch ein paar andere
Leute in diesem Land und das zusammen
ergibt dann eine
äußerst nicht unerfolgreiche
Produktion wie ist das wenn so eine
Platte fertig ist kannst du dann die
Sachen noch hören also ich höre mir das
ich wenn das jetzt im Club läuft dann
inzwischen dann freue ich mich auch und
fei das auch das war mir früher im
unangenehm
aber aber ich B ich h niemals ab dem
Zeitpunkt wo das fertig ist freiwillig
irgendwie meine Musik das höchstens mal
10 Jahre später ah was das Du geil hpiss
mich dann der will aber ich Bo ich würde
niemals weil das ist so schlimm das auch
klingt aber das ist für mich Arbeit also
nicht das Hören ist Arbeit sondern ich
höre da das Produkt meiner Arbeit und
das will ich nicht ich will doch Input
kriegen ich will an Musik ist so schön
weißt du ich will andere Musik hören ich
will nicht das hören was wenn jemand
wenn jemand den ganzen Tag im Büro sitzt
dann freut er sich darauf nach Hause zu
kommen und dann wird er sich garantiert
nicht an Schreibtisch setzen und
irgendwelche Büroarbeit machen sondern
er wird irgendwas anderes machen was
hörst du dann für Musik außer deiner oh
g ganz viel von allem also ich habe dann
immer so Phasen wo ich in irgendwas
reinttauch
m es gab mal eine Phase da habe ich ganz
viel rootwaggy gehört das war zu zu zu
den Beginner Bambule Zeiten als es alles
durch diecke Decke ging und mir die
ganze rapsache ein bisschen mich genervt
hat daraus kam dann auch searching
Platte dann habe ich danach z.B sehr
viel so so so Jazz Funk gehört und da
bin da voll eingetaucht und daraus kam
dann unter anderem auch Mercedes Dance
und dann bei Mercedes Dance habe ich
ganz viel rockmik gehört was für mich
bis dahin undenkbar war daraus ist jetzt
allerdings keine Rockplatte resultiert
kommt vielleicht noch kommt kommt
bestimmt noch
und jetzt bei dieser Platte habe ich
ganz viel nee während des Machens habe
ich kaum Musik gehört aber davor habe
ich ganz viel Zapper gehört und ganz
viel Johnny Gita Watson und ganz viel
Sly und ganz viel Prins und jetzt aber
nebenbei höre ich sowieso immer alles
und ich habe ein eine also die iTunes
Bibliothek hier mein Kopf gehört zu
einer der größten der Welt also wenn da
bei iTunes immer unten steht wie viel
Zeit Musikbibliothek hier drinne sind
ungefähr ich weiß nicht wie viel Tage 33
Jahre sind aber so viel 33 Jahre Musik
habe ich hier in meiner Bibliothek
abgespeichert sehr schön vielen Dank
bitte sehr